سالنا الناس وين سالنا الناس في السعوديه
ما رايكم بدمج حساباتكم الماليه مع شريك
لزواج اسعد ايش قالوا
احس انه اذا كان شريك الحياه يستاهل انه
ادمج معه حياتي ماليه وكل شيء طبيعي
لكن اذا كان يعني مو قد المسؤوليه مو قد
كده لا معلش انا همسك الحسابات ماليه كلها
بالنسبه للدمجه يعني الامور الماليه بيني
وبين الزوجه يعني في المستقبل ان شاء الله
انا اعتبره انه شي ممتاز وكويس لانه يعني
لحياه اسعد واللي زواج افضل وعشان يكون في
شفافيه ويكون في وضوح طبعا انا ضد هذا
الشيء في الوقت الحالي هذا يعني يمكن قبل
20 سنه انا بقول ممكن هذا الشيء بيصير لكن
في الوقت اللي الحين لا
هي فكره كويسه ولكن في بعد مده طويله من
الجواز بتبقى افضل مش من البدايه على طول
والله خطوه جريئه في ناس تسويها بس احسها
مجازفه بالنسبه لي انها مجازفه حسابات
الماليه
لها ظروف معينه اولا قد يمكن انك انت صاحب
شركات او صاحب اموال او صاحب علاقات دوليه
او علاقات داخليه مع شركات مع مؤسسات مع
هذا فانت ما تستطيع تشركها مباشره لا ما
في مشكله عادي اذا كان هم اثنين متفقين ما
فيها
مشكله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات